[Applause]
how you doing i'm fine i'm having a good
time
oh good oh great thanks so much for
coming here on the show this is exciting
number one song in the country that's so
crazy i didn't think that would happen
yeah i often don't think that will
happen to me and it doesn't
but for you i gotta think uh it's uh
it's still exciting even all the success
you've had to have the number one that's
gonna be great that is great i wanna
thank my record company they're really
behind me and all my
my people that i have working with me
they're they're really supportive and
thank you guys
my peeps my peeps that's like slang and
that means that you're a group of people
yeah my group
of people i don't have a group of people
he's my peeps yeah i'm peeps yeah okay
you have to say that every weekend all
right so
that'd be more like the little
marshmallow chicks
those kind of pizzas specific kind
now uh i heard that um that
that you're pretty uh intense about
about finding out about this number one
you call every day
is that right call everything we have to
check it every wednesday
we know what the billboard says before
everybody else
so you you call up and actually to find
out if you're still number one
i call well not to see if i'm still
number one but to see how the record is
doing
right do you think other people call in
too
is john tash calling in and saying
i beat yani yeah i did it
[Applause]
that's i didn't know there was a number
yeah well it's the same thing here in tv
there's a number uh
for the ratings i heard you do that too
no i never actually have never called
the number
i don't yeah there's my producer calls
the numbers i'm too afraid sage is lying
because i just heard that you did that
i called the number a lot
uh no but it's funny it's this recording
that tells you
what rating you got the night before
they always tell us we're still looking
um talk about things that are exciting
tv guide cover tv guide
i never thought that that would happen
because the last time
you're brandy of course this will happen
no but no i'm not saying i'm saying
because the first time i got the cover
of tv guy was with whitney
houston and because of the cinderella
right the only thing
i did and i didn't think that that would
happen again that's exciting
and my television show is not even in
its next season so i don't know why i'm
on the cover
well you know what's funny is i was i
was uh actually reading the article i
prepare
for these interviews sometimes and um
and and there was
something interesting here it said that
you once stopped a concert because some
people were talking
in the audience you stopped the whole
thing cold is that true it wasn't like
it was very innocent because
you know i think that's a good i'm all
for you sometimes you have the monologue
isn't going well if people aren't
laughing i go into the audience and
start hitting people
then they beat me up and i run back and
go i'm sorry well actually it was
um it was my listening party because i
wasn't i didn't
i was just coming out with the album and
just industry people they like to
communicate at these kind of parties and
they were talking so i said can you
please listen to me sing so you can
so you can see if you want to support me
or not and how old were you at the time
i was 14. that's amazing i think that's
very cool that someone who's 14 says hey
wait a minute
shut up listen to me that's cool well
they listen
yeah well they better listen you know
what's nice is
i just love this i was reading an
article on you and said that uh you were
really excited once you met
jaleel white who plays urkel and you
were really into the show
i'm just curious what was your response
to jaleel white
well when i when i met him he was
jealous he wasn't urkel so i was very
very upset so i asked him i said
why aren't you urkel i need to see urkel
i want to meet urkel and
he said well i'm not urkel that's not me
and you know it was a whole conversation
about him not being urkel
that's going to [ __ ] his life
for the rest of his life whenever he
meets a woman i don't want you where's
urkel
and he's 65 and he has to get out the
suspenders and
you know and hey people that's terrible
you know when you meet people right when
you meet people you want them to be the
exact same when you meet them in person
and i was very
upset because he was jalil he was really
cool he was like yo what's up brandi
nice to meet you right
i don't want that i want urkel
and he started crying and locked himself
in a room no he laughed
uh i think we got so little time tonight
but
uh just why i don't know why
oh because they only let us have an hour
every night they don't let us have the
time slot
after ours to bleed into more show it's
very bad i think some nights like
tonight we should have an hour and a
half on the air and you all agree you
should write nbc
but um
so i'll try i'll talk to them but uh but
before we do go
i just got to say there's one thing that
confused me i'm reading an article about
you and you said that you're
your dream guy that you the guy that you
would love to meet is a dime
and i know it's a slang term you taught
me one but i don't know what a dime is
a dime is a perfect tin i didn't know
that does everyone
know did you know that no i didn't know
what kind of peeps are you you know
oh i'm sorry i hit the mic well so so
what don so
you said that you said this one article
you said uh yeah i really want to meet
and
yeah i want to meet a dime now that's
just a perfect 10. like a guy perfect 10
a guy who knows how to treat a woman
who opens the doors who
picks up the check
has fdr's head yeah
actually i mean
actually it's truman i think oh is it
truman
check it home right now ladies and
gentlemen but i think it's true i'm just
trying to stop you from getting a lot of
angry letters
i don't know i think it's fdr settle
this at home
who's got a dime yeah everyone start
looking yeah
all right what's up i'm looking for a
guy though yeah
and you guys are messing the whole thing
up sorry
i'm sorry we're like we're nerds like
you're here trying to talk about your
dream gamer like no i'm telling you it's
truman you must understand
that's fdr is it fdr that looks like
truman to me
fdr he doesn't have little glasses
he took them off for the dime
you sure yeah all right
all right
you win again militia on upn uh tuesdays
at 8 o'clock p.m
everyone checks that out and never say
never is in stores right now but it
sounds like people know that because
it's doing great
so uh everyone go out there and buy that
brandy thanks so much for coming on the
program
really really nice to have you here
vr549 coming up we'll be right back